hey Mike what's up Rob uh we're playing
Battlefield one
open Beta word uh I believe it's
actually opens up for everyone tomorrow
I think so yeah I'm pretty sure um
cyanide desert map yes new map and uh
new mode Rush right yeah
um a bunch of new vehicles uh they've
removed and added different weapons but
uh we're gonna have a grand old time so
uh let's uh hit the game and get right
into it
um I say we take a look at this new mode
and we'll probably switch off here I
will um
play first
for a match maybe match two and then
we'll switch off unless you want me to
play the whole time I can do that uh
we'll see how are you doing fair enough
um we're playing on PC
as you can see with the mouse cursor
here
um yeah have you played any of this I
played a few matches so far
um huge fan of the map
yeah I really like the map
it's it I don't know I was telling you
earlier it feels like it's a bigger like
one battle going on as opposed to San
Quentin SCAR Where it's a bunch of
different ones and I really like that
map too as well yeah
um but yeah so you
you get oh
so who are we playing as here there's
the oh there's the British and then
Ottoman Empire looks like
let's join the squad here
um so yeah
opposed to the or Hatchet looks like
they removed it and now you get the club
it's a melee weapon and dynamite for the
assault class but yeah look you only get
one weapon here just select
um for assault which is interesting
so yeah they looks like they've replaced
the anti-tank
um launcher with uh
the
um Dynamite cheese I'm sorry I wonder if
they're just doing that like when the
game releases it will probably have you
know like the progression system right
some sort of yeah something like that so
that maybe that's just they're giving us
different items to test out sure
this is uh this weapon wasn't the first
one oh man
stupid and get on this
we have diffused objective butter well I
try to get off
oh
oh God
there you go
oh I have the dynamite I'll use that
is that preferable to anti-tank when
you're fighting a tank
find out we have
that do anything I cannot tell
no no I'm not anymore
enemy coordinates have been sent to our
artillery
two guys oh well you see the stone fall
down that was wild
yeah these Maps
oh my God my aim was awful
someone get him someone got him
what are you saying to maps
the destructibility like Levolution or
whatever they say is unreal music in
this game yeah we have diffused
objective butter
all right it looks pretty good here team
the British terms like objective butter
instead of Bravo right gets to me
oh before I go just defend I guess oh
look who's coming
oh he saw you got scared no I'm just
kidding
probably kill you soon
oh sniper man that is a a nice glare
I wish they didn't have that I now or
tone it down
Jesus dang
[__] ton of bullets
oh all right
got the vehicle nice
multi-kill
so you notice like I feel um
they've changed a lot with like the rate
in which you deploy I feel like a slow
down to me at least since the closed
beta yeah
just a close Alpha over there
for a grenades
not much difference there
oh man this jerk
oh he sees me there's a bold of you to
just come on Toe to Toe with him whoa
yeah right
oh crap
they need the sky
oh really oh I thought I had it oh what
dude went clubbing did I get a kill off
did I throw a grenade by accident
it's gonna tank here oh these are the
artillery truck is dope
um
it's really great hopefully I can get
into it cool
so you have like your oh what's down
there right there mobile mines and three
what was that three
what was that
did you just make that noise by pressing
yeah it did something
can you use this artillery while the
truck is moving uh I cannot so I have I
have a machine gun here and then I can
switch to this
uh I was wrecking people with this thing
earlier
oh man look at that pillar just go down
[Music]
beautiful
nice
again
what finish him
oh who is is this a bad guy
with a pistol variable to him with a
pistol too
oh someone shooting at me
so there are two like variations of this
map right with the beta there's the
bigger overarching regular
right regular uh control
this is Rush Oh this is looking good I'm
out have they called in artillery are
you the what's it called like an
artillery uh tank I believe I don't know
have they called an artillery at the
attackers when they take the telegraphs
from Connor artillery I don't think
they've taken any of that oh interesting
team is doing a pretty good job
this is not good
what do I have here let's try this
yeah I think so
cool all right let's move along here do
support anything do it AML no nothing
new here
[Music]
watch out
I'm really bad
there you go that guy's name is
multiplayer
when it's spelled with missing an E Yeah
someone already took the e
gave up whatever
you can find the delete button my
sensitivity is a little high
my liking
I feel like I don't know how much you
play I feel like the Sprint uh is taken
down oh sniped yeah sneezed
video settings
I didn't change any video settings
uh all right let's go back in here
oh that's a little better I'm gonna be
playing on PS4 later tonight I think
yeah
oh man you guys got a tank now too
they've added something to that that uh
the land ship tank we just saw they
added um as a driver which is kind of
cool because I feel like that's a that
um that tank is is very difficult to
utilize by yourself because you have
these two side
um yeah cannons that you need to have in
order to like do work anyways they've um
they added like the driver can switch to
a back turret
um and like Drive in a straight line and
use it uh the back turret yeah uh which
is cool
um
I think that was a smart move just
because you know it gives more incentive
to use that tank because you're not with
people yeah like and when I'm
not in it or I'm sorry when I'm just by
myself it's like
it's it's tough you have to like get
into the other turret yourself and shoot
other tanks
oh oh that was dumb
uh we fell back here
cool
I'll show it
why not
so watch I can just go
wait how did I do it
right so it just creates there in the
bottom right another and I can only I
mean I can actually turn too wow no dang
wait this is the rear tire right here so
if you notice in the bottom uh bottom
middle there is like the positions I
have oh they added
two new slots two two other cannons I
wonder if those are just machine guns
anyways yeah so I hit two it if you
notice it doesn't change or show another
turret I'm still basically a driver but
uh
that's over the top I guess
well this is a bummer I didn't think
that was gonna happen yeah let me just
flip back over
legit
yeah I mean if there's a tank over here
I'm just like outmatched
you later guys
if I can repair right uh let's repair
shoot
there we go
what is it x x yeah
I believe uh left bumper on the
controller horsey
[Music]
God right off
oh
there's something wrong about this
yeah so it you can but it takes more
bullets than a fully armored tank oh so
this guy behind me
yeah that was uh I took a walk a lot to
kill that guy
okay I come up crazy I'm good so now
oh duh
yikes that was close
pushing too much
what am I doing actually
I don't know I mean that was kind of
weird then it like positioned me oh if
you get out there's a guy right here
dude
yeah you see him right
yeah yeah do it again
teamwork
and missing
foreign
I think we uh
maybe I can repair
oh man that was crazy he just got out
and got shot
we're okay
oh back to it
see clutch dude that is pretty great
oh man they're everywhere
get another repairing
how was that I took it with you that'd
be with you
uh I hope he was on your team
I think so wait yeah he is
I'm I'm toughing it out I should have
gone it that's dumb
cool
oh he had cable let's
let's try this out so what we got here
oh I saw this too um oh weird
I thought last time I saw you there was
a there was a difference in a spotting
flare and then just like a flash flare
okay flash
flare being useful for what
I'm not sure I I mean I I'm just maybe
it operates like a flashbang or
something like that
I think Scout's my go-to class yeah it's
pretty fun especially in Battlefield
games well obviously but oh that doesn't
look comfortable
I feel like there's there's less of like
a a cheap feeling when you're sniping in
a Battlefield game compared to something
else yeah like you're allowed to Camp
right
I monopod is funny
sort of disc
Plus
even if I'm getting that lead right
yeah it's tough to get the feel for
I I didn't do much uh sniping in the
close Alpha
I did too much sorry you did too much
I was joking but yeah I do a lot of
scouting the assault class is pretty
addicting though it's just to you know
every other class whenever you are
confronted by a tank you feel useless
yeah
dumb
look at that guy
that guy so how many points did they
take any
I think they took one right oh they're
taking it right now I should go here I
should have changed classes
let me spot them for you
despise yourself oh
yeah they see it they see me now
I thought you killed him oh look at that
glitch there look at that butt head
I keep forgetting to hold space to
revive
uh yeah if you guys have any questions
in the chat Mike will do his best to uh
answer them just put a put a fat Q
capital Q before it so we can better see
it
all right goofy riot do you feel like
the lead is way different for each rifle
or mostly the same I don't know if I've
you would yeah if you could answer that
uh no I haven't noticed much
I don't know if there is any at all
there probably is but I'm not good
enough to notice that the bullet drop is
pretty noticeable though like especially
over longer distances
oh I was showing you this this is pretty
cool
um
like look at the crater of this it's
pretty dope
except for that time maybe it's maybe
it's just this area so I mean certain
areas are destructible not all of them
are like most area is we've Fallen back
I feel like they're gonna be coming down
here in a second
judging by him falling back oh
man this looks so good
yeah it really does
especially in like San Quentin Scar the
map you can see like the condensation on
your rifle
I thought he was off the horse
yeah
yeah horse wounded
yes for those asking there will be more
maps in the full game uh the closed
Alpha was San Quentin scars like a
French map uh this is Sinai desert this
is uh over toward like uh Mediterranean
Suez Canal area
um
yeah I'm not sure how many total Maps
there'll be at least yeah I don't know
if they've stated I don't know
definitely more than those two though
yeah
because they came around us oh was that
an enemy tank
I'm not completely sure when this does
go live in the UK actually
I'd assume midnight of the
12 a.m on the 31st right
sure
this is a good spot
yeah this
that's not good I feel like the tanks
are still a little finicky yeah I I
don't use Vehicles all that much [__]
that's a big part of battlefield but the
tanks are real can be really fun
ah
what
I might get on a horse show that off
we have lost objective apples
foreign
okay yeah so they push forward a couple
sectors
so then and then they get more tickets
there it was at yeah call an artillery
clear for the most part
defend the new objectives
which I had a
higher range weapon
uh after the match I'm going to ask you
like over our game like what you think
of the game so far sure people are
asking what you think of the entire game
I don't want to distract you right now
it seems like a pivotal moment
yeah
where no uh
prone afterward that was an interesting
choice
[Music]
I don't know if I feel like let's go
here
let's change it up
oh hello
go over the uh semi-automatic rifle uh
yeah I feel like this area here has a
pretty fat disc excuse me these Canyons
man where's this guy
oh really oh is that a different guy no
different guy yeah
oh I'm a medic
[Music]
yeah imagine if that actually has okay
yeah
man I feel like they're gonna be
creeping up on me soon
oh of course
I also wanna
kill someone with a saber on a horse
goal of the stream uh so far what map do
you prefer between this one and uh San
Quentin's car
um well to be honest I've never been a
huge fan of Rush
um all right I'm you know I'm a big fan
of like flying planes and stuff like
that and I like that well they have but
train they have the control mode on in
the beta as well right conquest yeah
Conquest so um yeah and I think we'll
take a look after take a look at that
maybe in a bit
um
but I love doing that
hello uh
I like this map a lot uh you know we
were talking about on the lobby like
these Canyons here for flying are just
clutch uh you know if you got someone on
your six you can utilize that and shake
them
um
this map I think just looks really great
and I I love the sandstorm element I
actually I don't think I've seen it in
full swing yeah I think it's it's
different across different parts of the
map it can get thick on some parts like
thin on the others
not it's not a good spot uh yeah and
like you know from the close Alpha with
the um
uh San Quinn um
what
I'm not doing too well you can really
see uh tell
um I'm sorry it depends you know not
every match had a set instance of when
fog would come in or like it would vary
in in degrees of it like how much Fox I
feel like that's cool to see here like I
have basically what I'm saying is I
don't think I've seen the sandstorm in
full swing okay
um and I'm excited to see that because I
feel like the fog in San Quentin it was
a little heavy
like too much
when like when you're in a blimp and
you're looking down and it's just all
you see is white
oh yeah I completely changed the game uh
it's I don't think that's that's that's
great I like the idea of it I think
maybe they could tone it down crap oh
man I'm not doing hot
they're moving up pretty well maybe we
should go back to this how much time do
you have left like okay five to four
minutes
see look I can't change any of the
weapons
interesting yeah
I think the sniper class has like a
bunch you can change
how often do you give a squad commands
do you do that often at all oh you can
you you um
dude it's a good cover on his part I
think that guy has killed you a couple
times
um
what did you ask oh yeah if you give
Squad commands uh in your squad leader
um which is oh that's me right now huh
well yeah I'm asking you personally do
you give squack man's pretty often or no
yeah oh like you get so like
you can really utilize that and get a
lot of points
um
I feel like it's even cheap sometimes
where like if you know like in Conquest
especially if you know like and all
right and like
in a few moments we're going to be
having uh we're gonna we're gonna take a
you can um just like jump on and be like
hey go to a and then you get points for
for capturing it right so you if you you
could just work the squad commands
and get a lot of points that way
if that makes sense
yeah I get what you mean
take advantage of it while you're
fired
I love how I just love Battlefield games
General how the scope of the battle
changes like now you're close quarters
worrying about like what's around the
corner right right across the field
right
oh cool almost
the enemy has armed objective yeah right
there see that's 300 right there
you should probably go to the new jacket
oh
good shot I know it
oh there's a guy there
oh you I didn't do me a favor
um when you respawn I think there's a
customized option for your weapons
people are pointing out they might have
changed it since go customize go back
can you change them here there you go
yeah that they oh we want to know why is
because I've unlocked I haven't unlocked
them yet gotcha
180 all right let's take a look at
um
this good point I for this wasn't in the
alpha
oh interesting so you could probably
then get the okay cool so I can get the
rocket gun later yeah so they did have
weird certain things just unlocked right
away for the um
well they gave you a a lot of these war
bonds
oh look at this pickaxe
spiked club
okay interesting
let's see now now I'm really curious to
see what else we have here um
whoops
oh look at that crutches in
rifle grenade smoke so yeah it's more of
a support class kind of thing yeah you
just completely change being a medic
well man get toward the end of the match
whatever
I was really curious to see that
hey guys I'm back
how about those menus
oh my God you just walked into a
Minefield of live enemies
uh I'm bad all right
do you want to play sure okay we'll
switch all right uh do you want to do
conquest yeah yeah I want to see that
train and even get to use it
[Music]
um
I'll show you up here
or do you want to use Mouse
yeah cool
probably do some scouting to warn people
do it all right Conquest
oh yeah I don't do they I don't even
think they have the other map here
all right let's switch
yeah the beta is just uh cyanide desert
I believe
[Music]
all right cool so if you guys got any
questions I'll do my best to answer them
all right bud
capture and hold the flags
of course of course course
oh sweet I wonder what sweet
mods you can put on your horse
[Applause]
so yeah you got like the class lever
action
sure if I can jump over things show
people how mobile they can be
so you gotta you got a saber sword uh
yeah
two two let's try this out oh man do it
let me get this first I feel like
[Music]
oh man those controls get weird
when you're like it's like a weird tank
control when you're coming back around
so
I wish you could have some of the back I
know right
those kids just rammed each other that's
going well
oh man I really hope I guess can you not
go on the left side oh you gotta line up
on the right all right yeah you can
change the over the shoulder as well I'm
just going right in do it
so the train acts if if you know any
other the other map
um people are asking it it's similar to
the Behemoth blimpse so it'll come
midpoint to the losing uh to losing team
oh that looks weird yep yeah in tight
Corners the horse is not
hang out here until I don't know what
they were doing oh this is going slow
this is a little awkward yeah
I don't know where they went I should
probably get off
what are my weapons gonna be like
when that's a good question do you get I
would assume you've given your clients
back right your pilot you eject you get
that pistol right yeah so I assume I'll
just keep this stuff actually you do I
did it a few weeks ago when I was
playing this at uh E3 okay so you keep
that shotgun it's not the best so you
have to keep in mind that when you get
off the horse you might not be equipped
to like come back deal with too much
whoa that was a massive lead oh my God
you've got a floaty oh guys to the left
guys that left yep where I thought I saw
a guy there's a shirt oh [__] yep shoot
oh never mind oh there was a scout damn
it dude how sick would that be if he was
scoping and I just walk up behind him
and
all right I might Scout him is there a
horse left
we're out of horses send more horses
out
dang we actually made good yeah look at
that
progress
what I feel like that's a really dumb
place to hold the gun
like the monopod of it yep
oh yeah get him
we have lost objective Freddy
I wanna go up against that
use uh use those K rounds oh he's gonna
come for you I think he's turning around
what the hell oh [__]
we have taken objectives yep
okay you know what let's relocate while
he's
they still see me
I think it's safe
at the very least I can
you use the saver on foot we're not
quite sure yet I I think you I will
definitely try one next time I can spawn
on a horse but you would you say that oh
all right
I forgot if you mentioned it could you
get off when you when you get off the
horse did you have that I had more
shotgun so I assume I would have the
saber that's probably just replaces your
club or whatever else you might use yeah
just try to get a mailbox right now huh
of course
I know
keep scouting for a second ah I'm gonna
plane don't do that
you gotta click the plane
oh I was gonna say there's you could
have actually gone whoa whoa all right
I'm probably not gonna pilot any
Vehicles just because
tight that was me I got it
shot
um
oh here we go here we go here we go so I
I flew up on tried to attack plane oh
nice I feel like the um I have
difficulty
aiming and utilizing the bombs and I
feel like they've they've kind of
finessed the like lead and drop uh in a
pretty nice way okay I can't tell this
guy's good
[__]
what is that noise
what is he oh
dude
did he does he have a a new weapon
because you can oh he's using like dude
oh my God I can't wait to see that so
that's so cool so I think they're they
they're what happened to that oh man
they had to have added it's like a it
looks like a rocket he was shooting he's
throwing like like a heavy caliber
weapon I think you're able to now change
your plane's weapon it's got a Dos rifle
dude that's so dope I can't wait to see
that we have to take a look at vehicles
I think I think they're slowly adding
the ability to change weapon types well
they did that with the soldiers I mean
like there were new
the anti-tank rocket was it's not
unlocked now where it was before it
seemed like the loadouts are different
than the close beta right or Alpha right
no yeah that but they you could change
your your
weapons and gadgets uh previously but
you could not change anything on your on
your plane remind me what parachute was
when I jump out uh space bar okay
so I thought but I didn't want to jump
and then ask
hello can you shoot your own plane I
don't think you can do it
can't pull a uh
Indiana Jones
that doesn't seem bad this guy's
actually a decent pilot yeah
there's no Rob Hamley
all right here we go
all right I'm probably gonna get out
after this next pass
during this next pass to
we have lost objective Charlie
not bad spot to land oh
that jerk that's a good shot though
probably my fault for jumping in the
middle of the village all right so don't
forget yeah I keep forgetting to hold
down spacebar to Quick Revive of course
nothing
for a second see how this goes
come on oh bullet drop damn
we have taken objective Freddy
it's tough
I don't know why I'm running across this
whatever
[Music]
I
think I'm good
looks like people are in there which is
good news for me so they're not just
focused on oh [__]
he came from this side right I think he
came from the right well they're not
that far
what damn they were far away
I feel like yeah that [__] he was
there damn it I'm sorry it's all right
all right maybe I should uh
off that for now
uh are there any rocket grenade
launchers to carry yeah so assault class
has an anti-tank
essentially like an RPG but you have to
be prone when using it um we do not have
that locked we'll have to unlock it in
order to see it uh but it's pretty cool
it's a good weapon I was a big fan of it
you could if there was like a sniper and
a tower you could just light that Tower
up you know he'll fall out
um
or just shoot guys directly in the face
like you were doing that one match yeah
I'm not sure what the situation is up
here
it's a little too quiet
let that guy going
it was too quiet too quiet oh man
situational awareness is not the best
right now all right
we should be seeing a train soon I feel
like I don't know we'll actually know
seven minutes is typically when it comes
in I think
oh [__] yeah yeah oh over there two guy
guy there horse Guy Horse do to the
right
oh wow
oh
and a sniper damn it
let's get out of there cause he's got it
uh
he's gonna come back I'll be waiting
yeah yeah yeah
ah look at that tank rolling
man that was a decent shot I feel like
he likes guys are just way better at
this game than I am
and that'll happen all right
let's figure this out
you get a plane there going near that
one man this is the tide has turned Ooh
Nah
should I no not an Allison keyboard
you get a tank too late
let's do this again we'll do it do it
oh sweet good spot
we have taken objective George
Cena he's in uh yeah
in that turret
we have taken objectives oh yeah oh yeah
come on
it's always out
oh good shot
thank you
there it is
so he's in the counter sniping that's
cool I just got points for that yeah oh
geez dude that flare through the scope
looks so good like the actual like
blinding yeah right I noticed the second
is that I think we got it
sick
that's why I kind of really like
Battlefield again I'm like 300 feet away
and actually helping take that Outpost
well I like to think I am no yeah
who's this who's shooting
I don't see this dude oh I see him
oh nice
nice chin
oh that looks good
no one has noticed me yet which is
worrying
let's go help out elsewhere oh I could I
saw that kind of parachute
uh snipe them
[__] oh you see him yeah hiking not
yeah
someone's to my right I think
where'd they go
we have taken objective apples
we got them damn we came back a little
bit though
let's do that
we are losing objective Charlie
this
oh here we go
come on
there we go
all right
anybody else in there nope oh
all right uh so just to clarify to
everyone
um
thank you
open Beta is Wednesday 31st yep so UK
I'm assuming it'll start at like
midnight Pacific time or just midnight
UK
yeah we have lost objectives
I'll be back here all right
freaking chaos nope nope all right
whatever
you have out here again
oh
we have lost objective Freddy another
dude it's not here oh he's dead death
animation what
Oh I thought that guy was holding a
stone it was escaped yeah there we go
all right
halfway there we have the upper half
bees good looks like they get that guy
all right sweet
looks Fair now
I think so sweet cool
all right oh that's right so we're not
seeing the train because it's such a
close game the ticket Gap would have to
be I don't know I'd like to say like a
landslide maybe there's something 100 or
like 50 maybe right
all right this is a good spot now
there we go see him
it's a bad place to stop but I'm pretty
sure you can drive the train yeah nice
could you drive the train driving uh no
I think there is a weapon right on the
front of it I've never tried but I know
there's like a cannon right on the front
I don't but it's on it's predetermined
oh well here's the train coming in
tracks oh okay cool I'll try to get into
it then
um oh man I love to do striping runs on
it with wait no we don't have it damn it
we don't have it right makes sense
where is it
I don't know I think it's arriving yeah
shortly
planes planes nothing there's a plan
there if you want give it a shot
that's uh
uh I'll stick to your soul
Target
not my forte especially with a mouse
keyboard
right I have a controller next to us for
that reason
oh right yeah yeah oh [__] I'm just
sniper now
oh horse
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah boom Oh I don't
have a saber though right oh I do you do
it just switches over here move move I'm
just gonna shoot you
Serpentine this thing so it looks like
you also drop and drop ammo and oh
nice what's going on didn't look like
you made contact no not at all that
crater oh damn it cool all right I got
one I wanted to see that the crater made
it look like I didn't get on that horse
yeah oh he just got
kind of run over oh there's this there
there's a train go to go to like a or b
yeah I'll go B let's see if you can see
it
oh God are you assault yeah you probably
throw some that's what stops all right I
wonder
see look he's backing up I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure uh there's someone
driving racks here I mean you can drive
the Zeppelin it's like doesn't seem like
this seems like a terrible idea it feels
like dude this is hilarious oh man he's
easy totally
screwed if I had a horse right now like
[__] like Great Train Heist robbery
sorry [__] the name of that up oh he's
totally driving it yeah I guess so
yeah I was wrong about that
I mean you'd have to like you have to
drive it in order to like make use of it
like if it just circled around how could
you like strategically use it like oh
wait let's go to a we need to stop a
right
[__]
[Music]
uh there's no one there anymore right
now
Sandstorm would be helpful to get over
there
looks like it's set
we have lost objective butter that
plane's coming real low oh [__] man get
the oh tank
all right okay I keep spawning at B
against
what the game is telling me
right
let's do this try to go for C are we
still good
oh wow we all spawn here good Landing
I wouldn't I wouldn't do that
it's on fire dude
what is hitting us right now
for a second
people asking uh it's unclear when the
battle will end
um yeah I have no idea I think last time
it was like a it was like a week right
it was a while uh so yeah you would you
know definitely over the weekend I'd
imagine
um
maybe like Wednesday of next week
Wednesday or Tuesday
uh we won right
you're winning yeah
three two do something cool last second
it's okay
all right let's switch I want in all
right
all right nice job did better than me
sweet all right so we'll get some points
here like I'm dying to see uh
customization stuff
turn a menu
oh can you put a metal on
is that what this is
oh no
oh yeah okay
this is interesting
so he put a metal on and try to you know
basically just like many achievement
achievements
destroyed 10 vehicles in a behemoth
this is easy enough
should I do this 50 times
how long are we streaming for one more
match
um
probably best for me okay
or I mean I could keep going yeah yeah
uh so I gotta see this where the
vehicles at
should be here right vehicles
yeah I'm digging the conquest way more
than Rush yeah
well I guess I'll just play damn
it's hoping I could
so look we can unlock oh we have to be a
rank we want oh I have to be at a rank
one an assault in order to unlock it
foreign
damn
I'm sorry what'd you say you're
installing something
or stalling oh stalling okay I was
looking at the menu gotcha
I have just I don't know do you think it
feels bigger
oh damn it's more Nuance the other one
was just this big circular kind of thing
right
oh my God
oh he's going for you no
start from the other side got the blade
in the face this time oh you killed him
someone dead
oh man I suck all right
let's do it again do you need our rank
specific to each class or do you need to
it seemed like it because I know I'm not
rank zero right like it
let's get on this horse yeah um just
pull that sword out and get after it
oh
what I just leaped it no I want to get
on it
wait whoa that looks that looks legit
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah go at that tank
with the sword
are you three and four explosives right
now what are those
um I I think they're oh God I think
they're I'm gonna jump over
interesting approach they are uh ammo
and and health I believe okay
one
damn plane
I don't even want to know if it's going
enough don't laugh
coming in
nice damn
YouTube saw that coming but
if I hear a woman yelling I did I was
just gonna say that
I mean they they showed the we got the
girl uh in the trailers right
I wonder if I haven't seen any oh
the magazine blocks it and I can't see
it it sucks over designed that Weapon
It's probably why they put him on the
side yeah
man I'm so shooting like a jackass what
advantage is there to having it on top
like easy to reload I guess
oh
yeah I don't know
okay go to F no
thank you
there's a lot of us here oh yeah
oh shoddy shotgun
let's hope you guys get the train this
time
yeah let's hope we hope you lose let's
let's lose
these tanks are
dope yeah it's a one-person tank right
yeah
[Applause]
it's got it should have also a secondary
shotgun for like infantry so suppose
like a precision
Cannon
um
but
the benefit of this thing is as graph
360 turret so like
so let's go to f
so you can just like tackle anyone um
all the other tanks have like mounted
or like just varying degrees oh there's
a guy there
I'll take them on
look at this guy
oh that was almost he's like oh my God
there's another one right here on the
hill Straight Ahead yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right
this should be interesting
Rock him
well then
settles that another guy right you're
right thank you
foreign
God
I got him now
what enemy hit he just went thrown
what how do you get
yeah someone's telling you to aim for a
plane if you get a chance oh yeah I've
done that a few times taking on a plane
in the tank
[Applause]
oh
it's a tank battle
oh he's got an advantage on me no who is
this
[Applause]
oh this cat
come on come on come on come on over the
hill yeah yeah yeah
oh
come back for more
all right
oh he's coming
oh
he's totally coming back for me
jeez
oh I gotta have wing damage
come on come on come on
I want you to do it I want you to get me
hit me
where'd he go
he's probably repairing
all right let's go take it
F here
[Applause]
some kind of chat just said beep beep
I'm a bus yeah I saw that that's a fun
guy
[Applause]
this is a wheelie bar I wonder what that
is in the background I know I was
wondering
what we got what's the situation
oh oh oh oh oh oh damn
oh [__] I'm all right I'm all right
bullet holes around you
crater looks so dope
oh man he's totally come back
we have lost objective Duff
oh
[Music]
yeah oh man watch him crash
let's be ejected right
well he can still repair
oh this guy
[Applause]
oh yeah I know okay oh man that's fast
oh see do that dude he's got like a
freaking Cannon he can totally put that
on wow that's like an anti-tank Cannon
damn yeah they put an anti-tank on on a
plane
what's next water cool machine guns
that's right
I want this guy to come to me oh is
someone shooting at me
we're all in this place
oh it was not paying attention but that
worked out cool
I see a little head poking I did
oh but I don't have an angle
I think I'm gonna get out of here
plane is gonna be coming here soon
so I used to have poison uh gas
looks like I don't no it's like just not
even present what's two two is that
shotgun uh one three is repair High
okay holy [__] what is that I don't know
what that is
set up an anti-tain I don't know what
dude that's nuts seems like a weird
place for it to be
come on really I'm not making any
contact
is he still on it what is shooting me
oh this guy oh he's got an anti
get him
no
oh man I should probably repair
always
do a pretty good job of holding e
yep
where are you going
there you go
tell me man these tanks light tanks are
so good
I'm into it
the art of repairing
all right uh self-help looking yes
a tank guide if you will
actually roll out
yeah man this just looks so good this is
a lonely match you're playing
well out here in this little Oasis
I love the dust I know I know
I wish I had some Treads that'd be cool
looking
track
all right well we're doing all right
I mean not all right but a little bit of
comeback here
this is the slowest tank
of them all
despite being the lightest
[Applause]
did you is the train rolling in yet
I mean I I guess a 20 It's gotta be like
50 or more I feel like
the uh balancing
he's shooting in it
horse
there's a few horses just hanging out
over there
oh Jesus oh God
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
hello
nice
I missed that oh my God it looked really
good
oh it's getting on a horse nope
no he escaped
oh
yeah you've been playing much more
vehicle combat than I have in general in
our time with this game
yeah I I just you know that's always
what I've been a fan of
especially playing
really close
yeah this is
good match
hey
oh nice throw
oh watch this done watch the other deer
there were two right really
oh there's one straight like straight
ahead right now
yeah up there
oh hey what's up wait wait one second
wait hold on hold on
oh what is he in that crater
so what's interesting about the tank
combat in general is you have to keep
reloading
or else your fire rate is significantly
dropped like you get like six shots
basically at your like right
Oak
oh look Oh I thought he was holding on
to it
oh that thing on your back
someone's saying that's how the tank
turns using that what balance I'm not
sure
huh
we have taken objective George
fire oh
was that reloading yeah
oh man look at all these guys
oh my God
hey guys no one is turning around fire
dude fire fire oh my God reload oh my
God
there's another tank behind you yeah
there's a tank right behind you
the call damn that was a run that streak
was long-lived
playing plane plane
oh there's a plane yeah yeah yeah see if
you can get the [__] is that the uh
I wonder if that's the one with the
rocket
oh I forgot I have to like look at um
changing uh yeah the loadout of these
planes looks like you can see look at
this is this is the we saw this plane
before and he had the different gun
right now it's just
oh crap
just like machine gun
whoa
it's my teammate oh my God I couldn't
even see that star
oh great didn't get any time with that
bummer all right
um
what's planned you want to do one more
you can play I'm gonna have to end here
okay if you wanna I'm gonna go one more
I'm gonna go one more uh oh that's a
cool couple cool wow look at that
the other guy
yeah you can take off I'm gonna do uh
okay one or two more cool
thanks Mike see you later
all right well let's get right to it
tyroot I see you in the chat
former Gamespot employee
my boss and a good friend
cool
next round here we go
all right cool I can get a plane now
uh yeah look at this package oh look at
this look at this
Airship Buster attack plane
tank Hunter oh yeah we're totally doing
this
That's So Dope
I wonder if oh wow look at Napalm for
the bomber torpedo
um
shift combat
trench fighter
harass infantry of the ground so I
wonder
heavier but slower rate of fire
huh okay
cool let's do it
oh man
let's party
I mean yeah I mean it you just you lose
a home man it's so hard to use
that's a hit oh look at that disabled
wow
yeah you would get out
I love it
we have taken objective butter
oh that's so awesome
oh come on more
what I'm not hitting you
damn I love it so much
crap
what we got here just situation
here we go
nice
not good
this is what I'm talking about I got a
guy on my six I can like go through this
Canyon and like try to lose them
uh tank cool
all right
oh armored car
then
oh yeah
oh man I gotta learn to lead these
nope too hot
oh he's gonna be
getting me
oh
all three baby
I want that horse
oh
[Music]
it's too late
oh
bad spot to be for his turret
let's do it
damn dude this cannon is so sick
oh nope that move I'm out
I love this map just just to like come
over here and then chill and repair uh
it's great it's got such great Terrain
nope
here we go
it's our situation oh Jesus God oh man
all right
anti-air
what's this thing right here
that guy did it
take an objective
time
let's do it
yeah that's what I'm talking about oh
where'd you go
into it
whoops
hurry hurry hurry hurry hurry
oh I see that snapper
foreign
what's next oh so E is good to capture
for planes you get planes
fire oh my God that was weird it got
stuck
foreign
horse time
yeah
yeah I did it
whoa
saw a sniper here
ah done I didn't see that goddamn
plain done I gotta do that again that
was so fun
wow look at the overcast it's cool
whoa we have lost objective
foreign
super realistic oh
see my plane dips because my left
ailerons out but I'm okay because I can
just repair it like in real life
oh wow it's like a whole it's actually
foggy so this is the dust storm I guess
sandstorm
see this is the perfect amount of fog
like I can still see the ground opposed
to like
we have lost objective charge the last
uh
Alpha
I can't see
but
come here
oh
dude I shot his head I shot him out of
his plane
how interesting how many of those bombs
do I have
to play was like four or five
two all right here we go
that was rude I should have rammed him
oh dude
damn it
uh
that was interesting I guess that's I
wasn't no I didn't notice I was like
dipping down
whatever
oh
last objective George
well this gun's pretty good
sorry horse
sorry horsey
oh
guy there
we have lost objective then
halfway there we have the upper hand
we have taken objective butter
[Music]
what's going on reverse where are people
all right
let's see defend
I'm squad leader Jesus we're doing that
sorry I looked away at a compost
who's here
we are losing objective Charlie
oh
shoot my pistol earlier
let's do the bomber
let's see what these like name Palm
Firestorm sure
cool
I guess it's these weapons this select
here let's see what happens
whoa
oh look at that fire
objective
oh
use some gunners
oh getting pretty close to the antenna
oh we're the repair icon isn't here
that's annoying
we have lost objective apples crap
let's do it
where you at
oh god oh I should have gone out earlier
oh Train's here
except I can't use it
spawn there let's do it go go go go
we have taken objective apples
risky
how many turrets does this thing have
one two
can three
four damn
oh the horse just spawned it was cool
though uh you can't do anything the
horse doesn't have any grenades or
anything
cool to like attack the trains that
but where did I spawn that's weird
without spawning on a guy losing
objective apples
we are losing objective apples
don't kill me yet
let's do this
come closer train come come come come
come
man that would have been so cool
where are you
yeah I'm Rob cat that's my name
uh
uh all right let's do one more
just write 10 vehicles on a behemoth
hmm
foreign
well
I'm into it it's cool map
I like this plane I'm gonna keep going
for it
oh what I missed it that's lame
whoa
[Music]
repair man
all right
there's guys not repairing it's not a
good sign
wow
quiet
I should tell these guys what to do I
keep forgetting
we have taken objective Charlie
we are losing objective Charlie sniper
we have taken objective dust
we have lost objective Charlie
and they're kind of surrounding us here
oh tank coming up
maybe he'll be dumb enough
I'm dumb enough Jesus
here we go
that tank
oh it's an enemy
a new bomber
there it is
we have lost objective charge
yep
oh missed it
oh
that is so cool
man
another bomber
what's up
oh my God yeah
oh no bueno
what
crash
all right
oh yeah
what we got
tank
this bomb sucks
yep
yep yep
oh and they're playing
another bomber people are loving the
bombers today oh he's attacking
the redo the mini map
hour to go
the last objective George
what we got show me
oh I see this guy
oh
yes
we have lost objective Charlie
horse
yep
leave my boy alone
nope
uh
come on yep I like it that's good
oh man dude this gun is so powerful
I see that is that armored car
hi
low
I already got there he is
risky
what oh no
I was reloading dude reload and ejector
the same button that's so dumb
I took it good
damn it
for app
oh yeah
I really want
to this is my plane
I think I remembered it gives orders
Jesus
uh
can I just like
he did shoot oh dude prepare
he's doing it
return to the combat area
uh
what we got
we have lost objective Charlie
this guy's doing anything Jesus
we are losing objective Edward
not good timing
you've taken objective Freddy
yeah this guy in here
what was he even doing
foreign
let's do it
he's driving my driving
I've lost objective button
go to uh
come on
Jesus
oh my God slow down
well this is distracting
Oh wrong one
that's weird
we have taken objective Edward
Jesus
foreign
[Music]
we have taken objective George
come here
what I
oh my God there's a lot of guys in there
plane
yeah
come on
beautiful
whoops
whoops all right
there we go
here we go
oh that looks like it was gonna hit
that looked like it hit
engine disabled I'm into it
oh oh oh
I think my wings got stuck on his wings
to it
[Music]
a lot of guys over there
halfway there we have the upper half
whoa that was a weird oh of course
do it come on do it come here
go
oh no
we have lost objective Freddy sniper
here
damn
oh he Bane added him I can see it from
up here that's cool
how to pull up
oh cool strafing runs on the train we're
doing it
[Music]
comes train
damn
of course it has anti-air
stuff oh [__]
dang
all right
um do one more match
foreign
[Music]
tank done party
so yeah they took out the poison gas for
this tank I feel like I mean unless you
can customize them
it's interesting I wonder if they were
trying to tone down this tank
[Applause]
look at this watch you can like take
these
fillers down
so cool
we are losing objective George
oh is that Emmy right here
oh he's trying to get in
ah that angle where you going
look at the bullet holes all over it so
cool
this game's looking real good
we have taken objective darts
thank you
don't let them take the objective
oh
heavy tank
not good all right that was good where
you going
another tank now sniper all the way down
there
hmm
oh he's got cover it's called dude
I can repair
ah
nope oh
what
I see sniper
crap
oh man there are a lot of guys here
that look good
yeah I gotta repair we have lost
objective Duff
go go
we have taken objective Charlie
all right
oh that was okay
all right okay
come on
oh hell yeah
twofer
oh
I'm on fire
what
oh my God there's so many dudes
oh my God
we have taken objective
yep keep it coming
here we go I see you dude
nope
this guy just here
we are losing objective Charlie
oh look at that blew that freaking roof
off
oh
we lose and see Magic
oh my God
oh good grenade okay
okay
some guy gets it
oh that's not gonna go well
[Applause]
horse coming
all right let's do this we are losing
objective Charlie
ah
we have lost objective Duff bummer
foreign
way back here if I can get him
oh
oh yeah
suck it
keep it coming
see you
oh trains here
oh this isn't good
yep I knew it
oh get out get out go
oh crap
move no no
no
not like this
all right I'm out
calling it
was a good run
[Music]
all right
I pick up no it's not g
oh my god oh
tank
oh
train's coming back we
[Music]
damn it
don't do it don't do it
what
damn accident
that really
look like I threw out the window jeez
damn
[Music]
right
oh did I get him
tight
we have lost objective Charlie
whoa
student class
I probably should have spawned near d
trans bag
of course
sniper yeah
oh cool plane
now they're going for uh e here
what oh dude that's so annoying
you're supposed to reload and it's the
same Button as eject
nice
uh
we have lost objective George
what's that
foreign
the hell is this
damn rifle
Michael's zeroing distance
what
damn all right let's get a vehicle
no vehicles okay
get up higher
it's gonna take forever to walk
a lot of people out here what's up
we have taken objective Duff
nope
uh we're trying to vehicle
here we go we have lost objective I'm
gonna die immediately I know it
foreign
plane just crashed
oh crap
bummer
all right one more
[Music]
oh it was an anti-tank gun cool no
yeah it seemed pretty beastly
cool cool
one more
oh yeah
duh oh great Mr Cool Stuff
stupid
right
um
let's get in this
idea
we have taken objectives wait
oh yeah
we're doing it
okay
oh
gotcha
unter
oh is that a fat Sandstorm coming I want
to get a view of this
oh look at that that's cool
oh that's neat
coming in hat
whoa
oh
cool
oh burning car
oh man I don't think I've no dad this is
new I haven't been in this storm before
Jesus
yeah I would not want to fly in this
oh man
it's tight
foreign
wow
we have lost objective apples oh
this tank is
all right
get out
get off get off oh stupid I think
they're that close
okay that's my idea
this is the new artillery check I'll
show this is kind of cool
we need to go do
anything
[Music]
oh [__]
man you can't see anything
we have taken objective apples
still someone here
to be
we have lost objective Charlie
oh man I can't see anybody
uh
George
Jesus
oh is that an enemy tank crap
see you still
we have taken objective Edward
yeah is there a tank here oh [__]
get out of here
all right you know what
oh I'm hitting him
again
oh this guy
yep I'm into it
there's someone's still here
horse
switch
more again
I saw you [__] horse again horse
[__]
I'm out of here
Sam
oh you're dead you guys are all dead now
oh good grenade damn it
can I repair in time
yep
we have taken objective butter great
whoa oh I was playing
oh
some of this terrain is risky to drive
over
lost barrel rolls
oh what's up
are you going wait yeah get him
oh
risky
oh man I hope that plane comes back oh
look at these [__]
oh
that other guy come back
other plane
because he should
a
what we got
them
that's a tank
oh it's yeah it's there that's there
yeah
I'm just gonna get out of here
we are losing objective Charlie
that Tank's probably right here
yep
oh he's gonna get me right here
I have any cover oh he doesn't see me
all right let's go from
here we're going
keep it going
excuse me now
horse
sure
wait can I customize a horse now
what a shame
let's do it
[Music]
to D
thank you
got him oh
you want to go
hmm
thank you
God damn
plane done give me it
gonna be playing over here so there he
is
I guess that's my guy
doesn't see me
crap I lost it oh there he is
[Music]
lead more
wait is that a teammate what is it
oh my God it totally is I didn't even
tell
I think it's harder to tell
what else we got
all right
look at this guy
even they're shooting at each other oh
no wait yeah you can't tell from a
distance I guess that's the issue
that's definitely a guy
nope
yep oh
that's good
yep
damn shot him out of the plane love it
God I Cannon
foreign
oh there's a tank
where there
yep
I have to chain oh
come on
oh I lost him there he is nice guy
gonna be playing
a little too close there
all right what we got
see a horse here
oh
that's a enemy plane
let's do the old stall move see what
happens
crap
Market
all right let's get a little crazy here
might as well just risk it now
hold on don't do anything just wait dude
let's do another horse
a minute left
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa Nelly whoa okay
we got ourselves uh
some Necco from oh yeah totally legit
yeah
great
hey
suck it
cool I'll go on that
all right
that'll do it
for the stream thanks so much for
watching it's been a long day
um I imagine we'll be streaming again
later in the week again this is open
Beta tomorrow
uh you can sign on for PS4 Xbox One and
PC all three and uh it's unclear when it
runs the last Alpha ran for about a week
so you get a whole week
playing this game looks like it's just
this map uh Rush as well maybe they'll
toss in another one later on who knows
but
that'll do it for us thanks for watching
again and uh don't forget to like And
subscribe on YouTube if you want to see
more uh Battlefield content down the
road
cool thanks guys have a great day
foreign